what's up everybody my name is harrison
and today we are looking at the top six
blunders in the fide grand prix leg two
so far in the 2022 fida grand prix one
of the most humbling things in the world
about chess is that even the best in the
world can blunder sometimes and so
that's what we're gonna be taking a look
at here today and i will say as of the
recording of this video we have only
seen the end of the first round of the
knockout stage so there are a few rounds
in the second leg that are yet to be
played but let's take a look at some of
the top blunders so far and by the end
of this video we're going to see the
worst blunder in the second leg of the
fide grand prix so far
number six on our list is between anish
giri and nikita vishgov anish playing
the white pieces has just played queen
takes g5 in a very dynamic and sharp
position here white has a lot of
attacking plants here but black's move
does not address any of them vishagov
went c5 which gives geary the advantage
after queen to g6 and now it is very
difficult to stop all of white's
attacking plans white can get the rook
to f3 to h3 rook coming down here to h8
and also the rook coming to h7 and
deflecting the queen from the defense of
the rook on g7 a lot of different
attacking ideas and unfortunately
there's not really a lot that black can
do visigoth tried bishop to d8 but it
was all over anish geary played rook to
h7 and vishagov resigned in this
position much better would have been
knight to c4 and then after queen to g6
now vishagov can play knight to d6 so
after rook h7 there is no
overworked piece tactic anymore then
this would have kept fishigov in the
game
number five on our list comes from a
game played today between richard report
and maxine versure lagrave in the
semifinals rapport just played f3 and
has a very nice threat of wanting to
come in with the rook to c7 and start
getting active with his rooks here for
shirley grove needs to play rook c8
which is a really hard move for him to
play because just two moves earlier he
played rook a to e8 so it's hard to
admit that you're wrong but instead mvl
played f5 which is a huge blunder
because after this very long and forcing
sequence of moves it actually allows
white to get two connected past pawns
the sequence is very long but it's also
very forcing looks a little something
like this rook to c7 first attacking the
bishop bishop must move and now a4
kicking the bishop off of this diagonal
bishop d3 now we can go d6 check king h8
d7 rook is kicked to b8 now bishop b4
the other rook must move but if the rook
moves to d8 then simply bishop e7 will
pick up some more material so mvl tries
bishop to e5 instead but after bishop
takes f8 bishop takes c7 bishop e7
there's now a checkmate threat so black
must stop this with king g7 and now e5
finally gives white those two connected
pass pawns and these two connected pass
pawns are just going to be too strong
for black to defend against and richard
rapport went on to win this game coming
in at number four on our list is also a
game from today with anish giri and
dimitri andraken geary has been building
an advantage and has a big advantage
after on draken has played h6 and here
gary should simply continue with knight
to h3 black is going to have to save
their night white can pick up a pawn
will be up a pawn and then black may
play knight to b8 to try to activate the
queen and the rook but simply bishop b3
and white's long-term plan here is going
to be to attack on the king side and
it's going to be very hard for black to
re-maneuver their pieces to the king
side with this sort of blockade
happening in the center so white's going
to have a pretty nice attack here and
definitely has the advantage but instead
of simply playing knight back to h3 gary
surprised everyone and played knight
takes f7 which completely allows black
to equalize after king takes f7 b takes
a5 and
white has traded one of their best
pieces for one of black's worst pieces
and white has totally messed up their
pawns so black is once again equal geary
and dimitri would go on to draw this
game even though geary had that big
advantage
coming in at number three on our list is
hari krishna versus nikita vishnugov
this time vishnov is not the one who is
blundering but his opponent blundered
here hari krishna played the egregious
blunder of knight takes d5 which can be
exploited in only a couple moves hard
christian was obviously expecting his
opponent to recapture right away but
vishnugov can throw in this intermezzo
knight e4 forking the queen and the f2
spot hari krishna would lose this game
in only around 15 more moves queen b3
bishop takes f2 check king to f1 e takes
d5
and black already has a sizeable
advantage here the game actually only
lasted 10 more moves before hari krishna
resigned definitely a huge blunder but
we've got two even bigger blunders if
you can believe it it just goes to show
that even some of the best in the world
can make really big mistakes sometimes
coming in at number two on our list we
have alexander predki versus mama jirov
here alexander starts with rook to e1
which comes with a pretty big threat
which mamadirov actually missed he
played rook to f8 and this actually just
loses a piece after f4 a simple attack
on the queen deflecting from the bishop
the queen only has two spots to go to
queen c5 runs into rook c1 and you're
gonna have to leave the bishop and queen
to e4 runs into the discovered attack
bishop f2 and black is gonna once again
lose the bishop again so black just
losing a piece here after f4 the simple
decoy tactic but alexander actually
missed this and blundered back he played
queen c2 the rare double blunder both
players missed this decoy tactic and
they would go on to draw this game and
last but not least what is the biggest
blunder in the fide grand prix so far
there's been 50 games in the second leg
of the fide grand prix so far what has
been the biggest blunder and this was my
number one on the list it's not just one
blunder it's not just two blunders but
it is the triple blunder three blunders
in a row dimitri on draken versus ettin
bacro and this is in the last round of
the group stage if ann draken wins he
will move on to the knockouts and if the
crow wins he will play sam shanklin in a
playoff game so both of these players
will need a win in the position on board
but crow is actually winning he's a huge
advantage but the move is really
difficult to find he's got to start with
king to f5 hitting the bishop and
escaping from this rook g7 check but
that's a really hard move to play
especially when there's this free knight
on a5 so the first blender this rook
takes a5 blunder it actually severely
diminishes black's advantage but you
know king f5 a very hard move to find so
we'll give him a pass for that andre can
continue with g4 now taking away this f5
square so the king can no longer come to
f5 and backrow plays a baffling move
which is knight to d7 i really don't
understand this move it seems like it's
just giving up a free knight i really
still don't understand this move and
after rook takes d7 black has completely
given up their advantage stockfish gives
this position as equal and black
actually has to find the only move which
is f5 the backwards defense of the queen
to the g7 pawn they should have actually
played it a move earlier instead of
sacrificing their knight but instead
backrow
comes in with the triple blunder queen
b1 and white is actually completely
winning because now there is no way to
stop rook takes g7 simply king g2 queen
e4 check king g3 rook a3
king h4 and but crow playing the black
pieces resigned in this position because
there's no way to stop rook takes g7 so
to go from completely winning to
resigning in only five moves to knock
yourself completely out of the
tournament that's personally got to be
my top blunder of the feeding grand prix
second leg so far but who knows we might
see even bigger blunders happening in
the knockout stage we'll just have to
wait and find out